[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein
rezept das sich vor vier jahren schon
mal hochgeladen habe und dass so
ziemlich jede woche immer noch nach
gemacht werde ich sehen es ja auch
instagram ist es mein 11 minuten nudeln
mit tool für schritt sap es gibt ein
kleines upgrade und ich möchte euch
heute auch einfach mal zeigen oder
beweisen dass ist wirklich elf minuten
sind und machen wir selbst mit challenge
und werde jetzt erst mal die zeit
stoppen
ich würde sagen top die wette gilt das
ja
also erst was ich mache ich gebe jetzt
einfach nudeln mit einem rudel eurer
wahl der g bis jetzt in salzwasser auf
jeden fall mal seid ihr dran machen und
schmecken sie sehr schade
in der zeit wo die jetzt also die
brauchen so zehn minuten in der zeit wo
die gar kochen mache ich quasi die
thunfisch so sind dies so einfach und so
lecker und die kriegen wirklich jeder
hin und elf minuten hat auch jeder im
alltag oder ich nehme jetzt hier kokosöl
und zwar das geschmacksneutrale das
werde ich jetzt erstmal in einer pfanne
ein bisschen erwärmt und schlimme in der
zwischenzeit meine zwiebeln stattdessen
mit olivenöl butter sonnenblumen raps
alles also man hat die zutaten noch
einfach wirklich immer da ich beeile
mich jetzt richtig weil meine zeit läuft
haben sagt du musst jetzt musst du musst
auf zack sein deiner kamera so die
zwiebeln künste ich jetzt an das macht
ihr am besten auf mittlerer hitze und
ich werde jetzt auch schon knoblauch
dazugeben
ich muss mir einfach ich stress den
immer entweder könnt ihr eine große
knoblauch zu nehmen oder zwei kleinen
ich hatte jetzt so zwei kleine da ein
upgrade besteht im gegensatz zum alten
rezept darin dass ich da jetzt noch
gemüse dazu gebe ich nehme rote paprika
und weiß nämlich noch dazu ich finde das
ist auch so mein gott wenn zum thunfisch
pizza geht da musste auch mal fabbrica
und meister zu und zwiebeln aber die
haben ja schon drin
pizza mit anderen geschmack ich haben
sie das versteht dass ich liebe pizza
mit ananas
sozial und knoblauch konnten jetzt einen
zweieinhalb minuten schön dünnsten an
der stelle gewicht paprika mag dazu ihr
könnt auf tomatenmark nehmen
ich nehme mal das was ich da hab ich bin
beides schmeckt gut und dass wir jetzt
auch noch ein bisschen angeröstet und
auch hier entwickeln sich schöne roest
herum und einer weiteren minute gebe ich
mein gemüse dazu also quasi paprika und
meist gebe ich auch schon direkt dazu
[Musik]
ok sechs minuten 78 sekunden meine so
ist es eigentlich schon fertig da findet
es nur noch gewürze und für die perfekte
konsistenz gebe ich jetzt noch ein
bisschen es kaum ein bisschen was vom
nudelwasser auch wenn die nudeln gerade
noch kochen und geht mir das in die
pfanne
also was habe ich jetzt dazu gegeben bei
mir war es heute schmandt einfach so
eine 200 gramm packung ich schreibe euch
übrigens die ganz genaue mengenangaben
wie immer unten in die video
beschreibung in der infobox und ist
cooler bei dem rezept immer machen wenn
ihr kein standhaft winter frischkäse
ansonsten sahne oder fettreduzierte
sahne oder in treskow kos milch oder
sojamilch alles ihr könnt alles leben
und ich habe das auch schon also gibt es
deswegen die mindestens dreimal im monat
also es gibt nie ne ausrede man hat
irgendwie immer alle zutaten so als
nächstes kommt die gewürze mit dazu da
nämlich gerne paprikapulver edelsüß
[Musik]
oregano salz und pfeffer und das reicht
mir schon aber auch bei gewürzen könnt
ihr einfach doch niemals sie am nächsten
liegt
so fertig muss noch die nudeln reintun
und dann können wir essen
[Musik]
ich würde sagen dass war einfach
challenge kannst du ich mich ins
schwitzen
man dreht dort alles noch ein bisschen
länger aber es sind elf minuten nudeln
und sie sind sehr lecker jeder liebt sie
also probiert sie unbedingt aus und
ansonsten abonniert meinen kanal wenn
ihr das nicht schon längst getan habt
und schreibt mir gerne euer lieblings
pastagericht jetzt in die kommentare
und dann suche ich mir da ein paar aus
und macht wie nach und ansonsten noch
ein wunderschöner tag bis zum nächsten
mal gekickt hat er mir gezweifelt
[Musik]